هذا وقالت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان
التدريب القوات الاوكرانيه على منظومه
الصاروخيه للدفاع الجوي سيبدا الاسبوع
المقبل في قاعده فورت سيل بولايه اوكلاهوم
الامريكيه واكد المتحدث باسم البنتاجون
بات رايدر عزمي واشنطن تسريع التدريب
باللي يستغرقه اشهر البدلا من عام كامل
مشيرا الى ان واشنطن سات تسلم منظومه
بعد انتهاء التدريبات
الاوكرانيه على منظومه
خلال مده تدريبيه من المتوقع ان تستغرق
عده اشهر وعندنا منظومه الدفاع الجوي
اوكرانيا
للشعب الاوكراني بيتمكن من الدفاع عن نفسه
ضد العدوان الجويه الروسي المتواصل
وقد كان لهذا التصريح ردوا فعل اذا قال
انا الايام الروسيه في واشنطن في تغريده
على تويتر ان تدريب وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه قوات الاوكرانيه على منظومه في
قاعده بولايه هيوكلاهما يؤكد مشاركتها
فعليا في النزاع الى جانب من وصفهم
بالناديين في كيف على حد تعبيره